immerse yourself in all the excitement
behind the scenes of Sky News those 2017
election coverage is virtual reality
most the stories we do they doesn't work
in the news industry know how they're
going to end tonight we don't
welcome to Westminster for the past
seven weeks the parties have been trying
to persuade you to back them at this
general election validate those 2017 is
over and here are the numbers we are
saying that conservatives are on 314
it's gone 10 o'clock and the council
having a look organ standing here at
that exit polls tonight what are your
thoughts on that well it's always great
to declare so early in Sunderland's but
you know I said in 2015 and I'll say the
same now that you know it's very early
days and it causes no fight what the
evening will hold and whatever the
results are the Conservative Party will
ensure that we fulfill our duty in
ensuring that stability so that we can
all as one country go forward together
you know what politics has changed and
politics isn't going back
Owens the town is wearing water before
that not as what happened is people have
said I had quite analogy of austerity
politic well in the last couple of
minutes going into school caster hung
Parliament's with the Conservatives
winning between 315 to 325 seats hope
you've enjoyed this behind-the-scenes
look at both 2017 sky leaders neither
coverage or see you next time